the star trek universe is still alive
and well decades later with movies
spin-off series books and games and the
trekkies of course are gathering this
weekend at valleys for a celebration of
the 56-year mission that is where we
find jc fernandez live this afternoon
hey jc
[Music]
live long and prosper you guys this is
great to be here at the huge star trek
convention i'm here with kit when did
you guys start this whole thing um i
think it was 1979
the technical name is the 56-year
mission that's because it's the 56th
year of star trek 1966 something like
something like that and there's
something for everyone here first off
autographs meeting lots of cast members
doug jones how would star trek fans know
doug doug is uh plays uh saroo on the
new show discovery also you guys would
know him from hellboy he was also in the
shape of water uh he's he's a great
fantastic person and there's interviews
happening uh interviews since you're
doing panels with people all weekend
long autographed signings like with doug
uh what are some of the big names that
are here this weekend well we've got of
course william shatner of course
granddaddy of them all my granddaddy
amar and walter koenig is as well as
tomorrow but then we have the whole cast
of discoveries all the new shows for
star trek strange new worlds and picard
there is uh outside of all the stars
there will be some a lot of memorabilia
that is out here as well
yes absolutely i mean
i tell you star trek people are just
avid you're so passionate and everyone
here is so kind as well it's been a long
time right i mean it's like it's it's
spanned so many generations it's crazy
last turn to your right uh these little
thingies here what are they why do i
know them well they look like tribbles
they're kind of a tribble like yes
triple is from the original series you
know the things that multiplied yes
yes
all the stuff is for sale as well so you
buy collectibles you can buy merchandise
someone's watching you want to come down
here how do you get tickets um so
basically we uh basically have the show
online on sale online for about a year
but we do have tickets available here
for photo ops and autographs uh as well
as some day passes okay i think hold on
a second
we're at a star trek convention but we
have we have gilligan and the captain
the whole crew here from gilligan's
island as well you got everything here
everybody likes to dress up thank you
guys what is what does this whole thing
mean to you the star trek experience the
whole pop cultural phenomenon
it's just it it is it spans like i said
span so many generations and gene
roddenberry's vision was just so you
know outside of the box for when it came
out and it's just it carries on it
carries on and now the new series and
what not just keep that tradition going
i love it thank you so much autograph
sessions happening all weekend long the
star trek convention is here at valleys
guys
space
the final frontier yes send it back to
you guys in the studio
long and processed okay thank you jc